MINHAZ KAZI: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
the standby to answer them.
I'm Minhaz Kazi,
developer advocate
for Google Data Studio.
MATT HAMRICK: And I'm Matt
Hamrick, developer program
engineer for Data Studio.
MINHAZ KAZI: Let's get started.
So Data Studio is Google's
business intelligence and data
visualization platform.
In this presentation,
we will cover,
what is Data Studio, who can
and should use Data Studio,
how can you connect your
data in Data Studio,
and how can you share the
dashboards that you create?
Before we go into
our presentation,
let's try to see who would
be interested in using
Data Studio.
Maybe you're are an
analyst who wants
to monitor internal business
metrics of a business.
Or maybe you are a developer
who is working with a client,
and the solution
you are building
needs a dashboard
built on top of it.
Maybe you are an executive who
would like to present results
in the meeting for maybe a
quarterly results or maybe
all-hands results.
Or maybe you are a
CTO of an organization
who would like to
provide additional value
to your customers.
Or maybe you are
a data scientist
who had just done
some great research
and have some
findings, and you'd
like to publish these
findings on a blog post
so that everyone can see those
and play around with the data.
Or maybe you're just
owner of some data
and would like to
visualize that.
In most of these cases,
the solution that you
need to work with, the
visualization platform
will need to be scalable,
interactive, cost-effective,
and high-performing.
And all of these cases go
very well with Data Studio,
because it is a visualization
and reporting platform that
is completely serverless.
It runs on Google's Cloud.
You can build engaging reports
and dashboards in the platform.
You can leverage
teamwork that works,
and you can use existing
connectors and templates.
And also, Data Studio is
completely free to use.
You don't have to pay
anything to use it.
Now, let's see what
it can actually do.
We'll have a look at a
few example dashboards.
The first one over here shows
us some website performance.
And this is a live
dashboard, as you can see.
It's pulling in data
from Google Analytics'
account of the Google
Merchandise Store.
You can pick different
date ranges here.
You can pick user type.
And this live dashboard shows
different kinds of metrics
that you can use to evaluate
even your own website using
the same template.
Now, let's have a look
at the second dashboard,
and this is an
economic dashboard
which talks about the Economic
Freedom Index of the world.
Over here on the
left side, you'll
see that there is an
overall score distribution.
And then, there is
the distribution
of all the other scores
that make up the index.
And as you hover over
each of the data points,
it will show you the detailed
information about each data
point.
And to have a look at
the last dashboard,
this is, of course, a
FIFA World Cup leaderboard
where you can see results of
different games of the FIFA
World Cup and how the
whole game progressed.
If I look at the Live
Knockout Bracket,
you can see over here,
as the data loads,
the results of every match from
the round of 16 to the finals.
Now, these are some
examples of what
you can do with Data Studio.
The way Data Studio
works is that first you
connect your data.
Then you analyze
and visualize it.
And then once you have
built the dashboard,
you can share it
with other people.
So when you're
connecting your data,
the way you connect
your data in Data Studio
is you use connectors.
There are connectors
available that
let you use data from Google
Sheets or other Cloud services,
like BigQuery, Cloud SQL, Cloud
Storage, or Cloud Spanner.
If you have on-premise data
in maybe PostgresSQL or MySQL,
you can also bring them in.
Furthermore, you can connect
to other Google services,
like YouTube, Analytics,
AdWords, DoubleClick, Search
Console, et cetera.
But here's the problem.
What if your data is not
in any of these sources?
What if your data is in some
kind of maybe external website
or in a social platform?
Or maybe its on premise
hidden behind some kind
of authentication method?
What do you do then?
That's where we have
Community Connectors,
and Matt will talk
more about it.
MATT HAMRICK: Hi.
Thanks, Minhaz.
So community connectors
are the solution
that we have in Data
Studio that allows
you to connect to your own
data that's not necessarily
in Google.
So Community Connectors has
three main points do it.
It's built in App Script,
which is Google's scripting
platform that works across all
of the different Google apps.
It's low effort to develop.
You only need to
define a few functions.
And it has a share
and publish model
that should already be familiar
to anyone who's used Drive.
To develop a Connector, you
have these three main methods
that you have to implement,
getConfig, getSchema,
and getData.
getConfig, the first
one, is just a way
that you can say these are
the configuration options that
are going to be necessary in
order for my data to actually
be connected to.
getSchema just
provides the fields
that would be necessary to
say these are the fields that
make sense for my data source.
And getData is the actual fetch
to the data source itself.
So this might be talking to
some sort of SQL database,
or it can alternatively just be
making like a simple HTTP call.
So I'm going to do a quick demo
showing a Community Connector.
This one is for Stack Overflow.
So what you'll do when
you go into Data Studio
is you will have the ability
to make a connector to any data
source here, so I'm just
going to search for stack.
And you'll see
here at the bottom,
we have Stack
Overflow Questions.
That's the one I want
to use, so I just
click Create Data Source.
And that takes us to this
next page, where we will
be configuring the connector.
So you can see that
there's a few options here.
It says, which tag
would I like to do,
how many results do I want,
and what sort should it do?
So I'm going to use the
predefined tag of Google Data
Studio.
And then I'm going
to go ahead, and I'm
going to do a
results count of 22.
And I'm going to sort by votes.
You'll also see
here at the bottom
that there's a thing checked
that says, "use report template
for new reports."
This is just provided by
the connector's creator,
and it's basically a way
to get you kickstarted,
where once you have
this data source,
it will give you something
that looks good already.
So we click Connect, and
we see this field screen.
You'll see that there's
quite a few fields that are
provided from this connector.
You have question counts,
links, activity aids, et cetera.
So I'm going to go ahead
and create a report here,
and this will take us
back into Data Studio.
So this is what Minhaz
was showing previously.
He was showing
pre-made dashboards.
This is kind of the editor
view that you would see for it.
So you'll see here
that all I had to do
was put in a couple of
configuration items.
And I already have
a live dashboard
that's looking for stack
overflow questions.
And there we go.
So you might be
wondering what's actually
going on behind
the scenes when I
went through all those actions.
So we have three main
categories that happens
with this connector flow.
We have requests
that are actually
made to your app
script's connector code.
We have the Data
Studio interface.
And we have the user
interaction that would
happen on the interface itself.
So the first thing
that happens is
the user selects the
connector in Data Studio.
That, in my case, was when I
was searching for the Stack
Overflow connector.
After that's searched
and selected,
we just do a quick
call to getAuth
Type, which is an additional
function you provide
that just says what sort of
authentication your connector
needs.
If necessary, we
trigger an authflow.
In our case, we had already
authorized that connector,
so that was unnecessary.
So we kind of already
completed the authflow.
The next thing that happens
is a call to getConfig.
And this is what
actually made it
where we could see which
configuration items were
needed.
In the case of
Stack Overflow, that
was the tag and
the sort options.
We share that
configuration interface,
and we let the user
complete the configuration.
And then at that
point, we make a call
to their getSchema
function, and that
was what was able to show us the
config fields on the next page.
We show that field
screen, and the user
can edit those if necessary.
In our case, we
were already happy
with the fields that were there.
And then we're just
into Data Studio.
At that point, the user can
add any charts as necessary.
Or in my case, we
had a template that
already had the charts created,
so it just did a getData call.
And it brought in all
the data that we needed.
At this point, Data Studio just
shows a chart with the data.
So just a quick
thing to mention-- we
have a Community Connector
Codelab that's live right now.
You can see it at
this link below.
And I believe we will also
be sharing that in the chat.
This Codelab is just
a great way to get
started with
Community Connectors,
so that way you can see,
what would you actually need
to implement it for
your own data source?
One thing worth mentioning is
how you can share the Community
Connector.
So I mentioned earlier
that this is similar to how
Drive permissions work.
You can share with just
individual selected people.
You can share with your
organization, organization
being a G Suite account,
and you can also share it
with anyone with a link.
Anyone with a link
is a great way
if you want anyone
to be able to use it.
All you have to do is give
them a link to your connector,
and they'll be able
to connect to it.
We also have a new feature that
we launched this week called
Connector Direct Links.
And direct links are
something that we're really
excited about.
It allows you, as a
connector developer,
to give someone a link
that's personalized to them
with the known values that
you can know that they'll
want ahead of time that also
can customize any templates.
So I'll show that off right
now through this link.
So before when we went into
Stack Overflow Questions,
I had to type in all of
the fields that we needed.
And actually, we've
had this happen
a couple of times before.
Since this is still
a new feature,
currently it's behind a flag.
We're going to launch it in
production later this week,
so it's not working.
But if this would have
been working correctly,
the Google Data
Studio tag would have
been filled in, along with
the result count and the sort.
MINHAZ KAZI: So anyone
could just click the link,
and they don't have to
put in the configuration.
MATT HAMRICK: Yes.
MINHAZ KAZI: It will be
already configured for them.
MATT HAMRICK: So normally
in this case, this demo,
these fields up here
would have been filled in.
But since it isn't actually
live quite in production yet,
there's small
technical flub there.
So one of the things that's nice
about the way we have this set
up is there is also a
publishing model that's
friendly to individuals
or companies.
For individuals, one of the
easiest things that they can do
is they can just publish as
is an open source connector.
This allows them to have the
maintenance cost to be put off,
where we'll handle making sure
that that's taken care of.
There's also the ability to
publish as a partner maintains.
So this is saying you'll
maintain your own connector,
but you'll also have
all of the freedom
to do any sort of
monetization schemes
that make sense
for your use case.
All of these guidelines are
available on our developer
site.
And I believe that link will
also be shared in the chat
below.
Regardless of choice,
this makes a simple way
where you'll be able
to share your Community
Connector with anyone
that needs to see it.
Next slide, we'll be
going back to Minhaz
for how Data Studio can be
used to analyze your data.
But before that, I'd just
like to draw the attention
to all of these
connectors that we have.
We're already above 100
Community Connectors
with over 500 data sources.
So we'd love to see you use it.
MINHAZ KAZI: So that's
a lot of data sources
and a lot of connectors.
So Matt, let's say I am a
developing organization and I'd
like to build a connector.
What kind of experience
or expertise would I need?
MATT HAMRICK: Really, just any
simple JavaScript experience
will do.
Since Apps Script is
just a JavaScript that's
run by Google, really
all you need to do
is implement those
couple of methods,
go through the Codelab,
and get started.
MINHAZ KAZI: Sure.
And let's say if I'm
building a connector
to some kind of web API.
If I already know
about [INAUDIBLE],,
how much time could it take
to build such a connector?
MATT HAMRICK:
Usually, it doesn't
take much more
than an hour or two
to get everything totally sorted
out, including some tests.
MINHAZ KAZI: Oh,
that's interesting.
Cool.
So we'll probably look forward
to some of our audiences
building some connectors.
MATT HAMRICK: Let's hope so.
MINHAZ KAZI: So going
back to the presentation,
after you connect to your
data, then you basically
analyze and visualize it,
visualize it in Data Studio.
We won't get to the
analyze part in details,
but we do have an
explore option, where
you can go in and explore your
data in a visual interface,
select and make a subset of the
data that you'd like to use,
create calculated columns, and
then started visualizing it.
And for the
visualization, we'd like
to show this nice dashboard
that was built by ClickInsight.
This is sort of a meta Data
Studio dashboard that shows off
different types of charts in
Data Studio using a Data Studio
dashboard.
So as you can see here, we
have a big number type chart,
bullet chart, donut charts,
also pie charts, bar column,
paired column, stack bar,
line graphs, stacked area,
scatter plots,
maps, and geoplots.
And all of these graphs
are available to use
in Data Studio.
You can take your data, and
if your data supports it,
then you'll be able
to use those charts.
Now, there are
some other examples
we would like to share that
uses these default charts.
Let's take a look at
first the economic data.
This has some
economic information.
We've already shown
this dashboard
once that shows the distribution
of the World Freedom Index
by different countries.
And there's another dashboard,
which is the Google Analytics
dashboard that was created
by the Google News Initiative
Team.
This is focused more
towards news websites.
And this is more of an
experience than a dashboard.
And we'll show you
what this means.
We'll first search for the
Google Merchandise Store
analytics data.
And as you select
it, this dashboard
will fetch data from
your Analytics account
and populate the
entire dashboard.
And you can see that this
dashboard is, right now,
loading the data.
And as it loads,
the whole dashboard
will basically show the flow
of the visitors to your website
and how they are converting
to different measures.
And those numbers will
show up, and you can read
through the different text.
And the dashboard will
explain what is happening.
So you can easily use
Data Studio to create
interactive infographics.
And then we also have this
very nice dashboard that
uses a Community Connector.
This dashboard uses the Google
Fit Community Connector,
and this was created
by Datasaurus-Rex.
And this most likely has some
dummy data populating this,
but you can copy this dashboard
and use the Google Fit
Community Connector to
populate this using your data.
And only you have access
to your dashboard,
and no one else will
be able to see it.
In this dashboard,
you can see you
can track average weight
over last two weeks,
average activity
over last 28 days,
and average steps taken
over last 28 days.
And this gives you
a nice overview
of what is happening
in your life.
And lastly, we have this other
example which shows IoT data.
This is pulling in data
from a BigQuery database,
and it is pulling in data
for different sensors.
If you have IoT data maybe in
BigQuery, maybe in Cloud SQL,
or maybe in some
other sources, you
can pull those in and visualize
those IoT data in Data Studio
and share the results
with other people.
Now, you have
connected to your data.
You have visualized it.
But maybe when you're
visualizing it,
you're missing some specific
type of visualization,
or the visualizations that
are available in Data Studio
doesn't necessarily
work for you.
For that, we have a new feature
that is in Developer Preview
right now that is
called Community Vis.
What this lets you do is
build your own visualization
in JavaScript, and then you can
bring that into Data Studio.
And we have the documentation
available in our developer
site.
It will tell you how you can
build your own visualization.
And we'll also take a
look at a live example.
Let's have a look
at the showcase
and see what different
examples we have.
So let's say we'll look at
this Sunburst dashboard.
So Matt, if someone is trying
to build a visualization--
if they already know D3 and
already can build a base,
how much difficult is it
to bring that visualization
into Data Studio?
MATT HAMRICK: I would
say if you're already
familiar with the
visualization library you're
looking to use, it's probably
35, 45 minutes for this one.
It's a little bit simpler.
MINHAZ KAZI: OK, that's
very interesting.
So maybe we'll have more
of our audience bringing
visualizations for Data Studio.
MATT HAMRICK: Let's
hope for that too.
MINHAZ KAZI: So as
you can see, this
is a JavaScript-based
visualization built in D3,
and that's being visualized
in Data Studio right now.
And it'll work with other Data
Studio functions, like filters.
If you are using dropdowns,
all that will work with this.
This is right now in
Developer Preview.
So if you'd like
to use this, you
can go to our developer
site and sign up
for the developer preview.
So you've collected your
data, you've analyzed it,
and you have visualized it.
But now, you'd
like to share this.
There are different
sharing models
available in Data Studio.
So first of all, you can share
the reports using the G Suite
or Drive permissions, so
just the same way you'd
share Docs, Slides, you
can similarly share reports
with other people.
You can share them by user
or across your organization,
or anyone with a link.
And you can also give people
View access or Edit access.
If you give someone
View access, they'll
only be able to view the
dashboard and [? pair them ?]
with the controls
on the dashboard,
but they won't be able to change
anything in the dashboard.
But if you give
them Edit access,
they can use the data sources
available in the dashboard
and create new
charts and graphs.
Now, there's a
separate data model
available for data
sources that you add.
As you remember,
data sources are
when you use connectors to
connect to specific datasets,
those are added as data
sources in Data Studio.
Data sources can also
be shared with users.
Data sources can have
Viewer's credentials
or Owner's credentials.
What that means is if you create
a data source with Owner's
credentials and you
create the data source
and then you add the data
source to a dashboard, anyone
who views that dashboard
will see your data.
However, if you
create the data source
with Viewer's credentials and
then you create a dashboard
with that, whoever is
viewing the dashboard
will see their data.
An example of this would be
Google Analytics dashboard,
where if you put in
Viewer's credentials,
it'll be the same dashboard.
But when you view it, you
will see your accounts,
but when someone
else views that,
they'll see their accounts
in the same dashboard.
Data sources can also be
shared with View access
or Edit access.
And when you create
a dashboard, you
can also embed it as a
report or infographic
on different websites.
We currently support
iFrame-based embeds
and also oEmbed.
Let's see two examples.
This first one is, I believe,
a blog post on the Google Cloud
Big Data blog, where
there was a-- we
made a blog post on the bitcoin
blockchain data in BigQuery.
And as you can see here,
this is a normal blog post,
but this dashboard is an
interactive Data Studio
dashboard that has been
embedded using iFrame.
And this second link that
we have is another blog
post made on Medium by
one of the developer
advocates at Google.
And this dashboard over here
visualizes all the FIFA World
Cup goals so far.
And you can play
around with the data.
You can filter it.
It also changes the links
based on your selection.
And you can view
details on demand
as you hover over
different data points.
So once you've
built a dashboard,
you can also use it
as a presentation.
Instead of using a slide, if
you're giving a presentation
and if you want to show it
as you're presenting it,
you can show the
dashboard full screen
and play around with it,
use different filters.
Also, in Data Studio, you can
use the Community Connectors
to build push button solutions.
What that means is maybe the
users you are trying to reach
do not know SQL.
Maybe they don't know about
the database that you're using.
Maybe they don't
know the schema.
Maybe they don't even know
how to use Data Studio,
or they have a
constraint of time.
What they would
like to do is they'd
like to connect to
your data source,
provide some configuration,
view their data,
and then have a
templated result.
So you can do that using
Community Connectors.
What you can do is you can
create a Community Connector.
You can attach a template to it.
And once the template
has been attached,
you can deploy the Community
Connector using a single link.
And what will happen
then is your user
will come in, click on that
link, view the configuration.
And they'll fill in the
configuration, click Connect,
and they'll see a templated
dashboard with their data.
And that dashboard will
be created only for them,
and they'll be able to edit it.
They can share it if they
want, or they can just
view it for themselves.
Let's see an example
of what we mean.
So this is a dataset
available in BigQuery.
This is a Chrome User
Experience Report
that has data for over five
million different URLs.
And it will contain
data about timing
for First Paint, First
Contentful Paint,
DOMContentLoaded, and onload.
And it will show the
distribution of time
for all of these websites.
You can further dig down into
the data using dimensions
like Effective Connection Type,
like 4G, 3G; device type--
phone, tablet, or
desktop; or which country
the users are coming from.
So all of this data is
available in BigQuery.
If you Google the BigQuery
site for this dashboard,
you can see that this data
is kept there by month.
Now, if anyone wants
to access this data,
they'll have to go into
BigQuery, create their own SQL,
and then run the SQL.
And then they can
access the data.
And if they want
to visualize it,
they can bring the data into
Data Studio using the BigQuery
connector.
That is the more
longer way and if you
want to get finer control.
But if you're, let's say,
the owner of this data,
and if you want to give a more
easier solution to your users,
what you can do is create
a Community Connector.
And we've done that and
we'll show you the example.
So after creating the
Community Connector,
all you give to your users
is just this one URL.
So we click on this URL, and
we'll go into Data Studio
with that connector selected
and waiting for configuration.
And Matt, I believe we can
also use this new feature
to pre-configure
this configuration.
MATT HAMRICK: Yes, this would
be able to be pre-configured
as well.
MINHAZ KAZI: Awesome.
So we will add in a URL.
Let's say we'll
put in Wikipedia.
And we'll enable this parameter
to be modified in the report.
So we'll click Connect, Allow.
And the schema looks fine.
And we'll click
on Create Report.
So this will fetch the data
from the BigQuery database
and then create a
live connection.
And then it will
showcase that data
in this dashboard that is
created only for my user.
And I can edit this.
I can also share this
with other people.
And as you can see, we
have different pages
available for this
dashboard that
uses the data for Wikipedia.
Now, we have three
different pages.
And we can also view it.
Now, this dashboard is created
only specifically for me,
so I can go ahead and
edit it and this will not
edit the template.
So I can go into the
first page, and maybe
I also want to see this
data for a separate website.
So as you can see, this is
a completely drag-and-drop
interface where I can
make any kind of changes.
I will move this
one to the left.
And we'll try to quickly make
some new changes to this.
So rotate this.
We'll pick all the
elements on the dashboard
that can be configured.
We'll copy-paste them.
We'll move them to the side.
And let's say we will
change the parameter
to have a different website.
So maybe we'll
look at Google.com.
So as you can see,
this is completely
configurable by the dashboard.
And as we type in the
new configuration,
we have this
side-by-side comparison
for the website performance
of these two websites.
And once I've done
that, I can go in
and I can share this
report with other people.
I can share this by link and
publish this on a website.
I can share this with specific
people within my organization.
Or I can even share this
across my organization.
But this is how you can build
a completely push button
solution using Community
Connectors in Data Studio.
So to recap, Data Studio
is Google's free business
intelligence and
reporting platform.
And you can connect
to any data source
and make any visualization
that you want in Data Studio.
And you can share
your visualizations
with others in different ways.
If you are trying to know
more about Data Studio,
you can build a
dashboard by going
into datastudio.google.com.
If you want to see more examples
of dashboards built in Data
Studio, you can go to
datastudio.google.com/gallery.
This has templates from our
users and different partners.
You can also have a look at
the Community Connector gallery
by going to
datastudio.google.com/data.
You can get support by going to
support.google.com/datastudio.
If you're more into
developing solutions,
maybe Community Connectors
or Community Vis,
you can go into
our developer site,
which is available
at developers.googl
e.com/datastudio.
We also have an open source
repository available which has
examples of different code,
and you can go there by going
to github.com/googledatastudio.
If you build something cool--
maybe an awesome dashboard,
maybe a connector, maybe a vis--
share that with us by using
the hashtag #googledatastudio.
And now, stay tuned
for live Q&A. We'll
be back in less than a minute.
Welcome back to the Q&A session.
Looks like we have a few
questions from our audience.
So the first question is, can
we integrate graphs and reports
created using Data Studio
directly with Web Applications?
And it also us about
real-time reports.
MATT HAMRICK: I'll go
ahead and take this one.
MINHAZ KAZI: Sure.
MATT HAMRICK: So we can
integrate graphs and reports
in Data Studio directly
in the Web Apps.
We kind of showed off
a few examples of that.
There was the blog post
that Minhaz showed.
Those links should
be available as well.
Real-time reports
aren't currently
supported in terms of
updating as they go.
But if you just click
the Refresh button,
it'll always make
the date alive again.
MINHAZ KAZI: So I'm assuming
that we don't support streaming
data yet, but if you manually
refresh the dashboard,
it will get updated.
MATT HAMRICK: Yeah,
that's correct.
There's no streaming
data yet, but you
can go ahead and just
click the Refresh button
and get up-to-date
data that way.
MINHAZ KAZI: Maybe we can
also show the developer page
on how we can integrate
different reports in web pages.
So we have a page for that.
And if we go in quickly--
oh, all right.
So we'll bring that up later.
The second question is, what
are the ways Data Studio creates
simple reports from
databases such as MySQL
via store procedures?
So if you already have a
store procedure in MySQL
and if you have a
view based on that,
you can simply connect to
MySQL using the MySQL connector
and then connect to that view.
Currently, we don't support
passing in parameters from Data
Studio to that store procedure.
But that's something
we're looking into
and might be supported
in the future.
But if you have a view that
uses the MySQL store procedure
and doesn't require
a parameter input,
then you can just use that view.
Third question is, how does
one stop Data Studio reports
from running queries
in the background?
So Data Studio doesn't really
run queries in the background.
There are several times
when it will run queries.
First is that if it knows
that there are certain queries
it can make beforehand that
will speed up your report,
then even before
you open the report,
it'll sort of pre-fetch
some queries and store them.
The next time you open the
report, it won't run the query.
It will just fetch
from the cache.
When you're building a
report, every time you
add a component or every
time you edit a database
that requests Data
Studio to get new data,
then it will create a new query
and then pull that data in.
If you're viewing a dashboard
and the results are already
in the cache, then it
won't run the query.
It will just fetch the
data from the cache.
If you're the owner
of the dashboard
and if you manually
refresh the data,
then it will run
the query again.
If you're having issues with
multiple queries running--
let's say if you're connecting
to a BigQuery dataset,
and if you're getting a lot of
queries, one thing you could do
is maybe you can create
a Community Connector
and set up your
own caching ware.
You can cache to Firebase.
You can cache to Cloud SQL.
And then you can set up logic
where the first time the data
is being pulled, it
will pull from BigQuery
and then cache it
in the middle layer.
And then the following
times the query is run,
it will fetch from that cache.
And that will significantly
save on your query costs.
This fourth question
we have is, can one
connect Google Cloud Datastore
to Google Data Studio?
MATT HAMRICK: I'll go
ahead and take this one.
MINHAZ KAZI: Sure.
MATT HAMRICK: So the
short answer is yes,
and the slightly longer
answer is not right now.
So the reason the
answer is yes is
because we can make a Community
Connector that connects
to Google Cloud Datastore.
I don't think we currently
have a first-party connector
to Google Cloud
Datastore, but that
would be a great one to put.
So if somebody is
struck by inspiration,
that would be a
good one to make.
And then go ahead and
give us a pull request
on our GitHub repo.
MINHAZ KAZI: That sounds good.
And the last
question we have is,
can one export report to Sheets?
You can't export
the whole report.
Like if you have, let's
say, a 10-page dashboard
where each page has
five or six elements,
you can't export the
whole thing as a whole.
But what you can do
is on a dashboard,
if you have different elements,
if you hover over an element,
there'll be a small icon that
will come up on the top right.
And if you click
on it, you'll be
able to export the underlying
data for that element
to the Sheet.
So if you click Export
to Sheet, whatever
data was used to
create that report
or create this one element
will get exported into a Sheet
where you can use that data
and then create your own chart
or graph in Sheet, or maybe
even add additional data to it.
And that's all the
Q&A we have for now.
Thanks for joining us, and stay
tuned for the next session, "CE
Chat--
Digital Transformation
for Non-Digital Natives."
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]